my I'm going to talk about Universe let
me talk about Universal okay for those
of you around the world out here in LA
we have there's two theme parks okay you
have Disney World land right which is
the one you want to go to
all right
they know I'm gonna sit down for this so
you guys know that this is coming from
the heart okay
so anyway Universal it's it's like they
make they're making [__] on the lot and
then up top the people that go to their
movies they have all of these [__]
rides that you go on so every once in a
while a new ride opens up and if you
have kids your kids want to go on it so
the new Mario World ride
opened up and we went there and my wife
my wife
um
I don't know what she did like she
always buys the VIP [__] she goes don't
worry she goes we have the VIP you know
we can just [__] go in and but our
VIP [__] didn't count on the new ride
they're like yeah that doesn't count
like what are we talking about we paid
an extra 100 bucks per ticket they're
like yeah that's for the other rides
you know
do you remember Joe Dirt you remember
that the Joe Dirt ride you can get on
that shout out to David Spade the Joe
Dirt ride it's a [__] 69 super B that
does a loop-de-loop you can say I don't
want to [__] go on that well you
wouldn't have to stand in line there's
no one in that line you [__] it's a
[__] movie from 30 goddamn years ago
we have the Tango in cash [__] water
ride
it's it's good for that but any of this
new [__] so we go into like Mario World
and the first thing we did we got there
early we stand in line for this [__]
ride dude it was two hours and 40
minutes to get on the [__] ride dude
every time you thought you'd gone up the
last flight of stairs and gone into the
last room
they had and there was no Refreshments
no nothing so people are getting
dehydrated and then they keep bringing
you outside of the structure and I'm
going on you know it's one of those
fights you don't want to have with your
wife
in that line because there's no you
can't walk away right you're just
standing there you don't want to start
anything and I'm just sitting there
thinking like what the [__] didn't you
get the [__] goddamn [__]
you know
you always know where the best [__] is
how did you [__] this up right
I was like the dad in Poltergeist you
know you moved the gravestones but she
didn't move the bodies why that's what I
wanted to do
you got VIP tickets but it didn't count
on this [__] right
so two hours and 40 [__] minutes
standing in line
it was so bad in the beginning I
actually I felt for everyone around me
going like how can you do this to these
hard-working Americans this is [__]
terrible to run a business like this
people come here they're with their kids
people are crying but within an hour of
this I was I just hated everybody and I
was like you know what these [__]
people deserve it look at it
a bunch of fat [__] standing here
[__] [__] in front of me they cut us
they did this thing where they were like
they sort of like saw how long the line
was and they'll say it was like going
all the way that way they sort of got to
like you know it was like you know only
like five or ten groups of people and
they kind of went like is that the law
is that is that like is that like the
line and then they were just [__] in
it and like that was like an hour of my
life
going why didn't I say anything
you know I didn't say anything because
they all outweighed Me by at least 120
pounds
yeah morbidly
morbidly obese in their 20s primary
their life you know should be running
down the beach like they're in Baywatch
carrying that little thing whatever that
thing was for like what was that thing
football
I'm in the ocean that's what I'm going
to hang on to you're going to put it in
your teeth and [__] swim back with
your big [__] heavy fake 90s titties
like we're not going to go down to the
ground
you might as well put cement shoes here
right we went with another dad and his
kid and his kid an hour and 50 minutes
in was just hanging over
the [__] banish Banner thing
and he's going this is the most boring
thing ever
it was like bombing and staying up for
two hours and 40 straight [__]
minutes I remember one point I was
sitting up on the thing because I
finally had to sit down and I was up on
the top thing and I was sitting there
and I saw somebody walking down dressed
as Super Mario and I'm like I know this
[__] is going to tell me to get off
this [__] thing and I am not moving
and she just came like
[__] on the dick
could you not bring relief to your lower
back after this ungodly wait for three
and a half minutes I mean semi good time
that's why I love my wife she was
sitting on the lower one and I was
sitting there and the dab we were with
was looking at us waiting to acknowledge
the authority and neither one of us did
and she just kept walking because you're
not sit down there
like that
and she never did anything and we never
[__] moved
I just took the guys like I'm not
[__] moving what are you gonna do
throw me out and end this
so we finally get into like this room
they're like okay everybody I [__] do
it and they bring us like a whole group
of us
they're like come on everybody I see
space I see see space keep walking in
all right we're looking at trash
compactor thing from the movie you guys
like right the [__]
Star Wars all right yeah [__] yeah
buddy
[__] Star Wars man [__]
live long with Chewbacca in your buck
Roger Beady Beady [__] right so
there will be one person that comes up
oh that's Star Trek they do that in Star
Trek all right
Star Trek has May the force be with you
right is that how you do it
oh wait that's Hitler it's hard it's
hard to keep them all keep track of all
of them so we get in this [__] room
and then this poor woman right she's got
like the uh the drive-through
the drive-through microphone she's like
all right everybody's in okay and we've
been waiting for two hours and 40
minutes and she has the [__] balls to
go all right you guys ready to ride the
Super Mario ride
and the parents are like yeah
yes we are that was the entire purpose
of this exercise
and you know the deal when somebody says
are you ready no matter how much you say
you're ready it's never enough right so
we're standing that she's like oh come
on
this is the Super Mario ride you could
do better are you ready to ride the
Super Mario ride and everybody's like
with the last bit of [__] hydration
we have in our body we're like yeah
tell me where the dick is and I will
suck it please
let this part of my life end right and
then guess what happens nothing
nothing cause the ride has not arrived
on the other side so now she has to
filler bust and she's not good at it
going like this ride took over 75
[__] hours to whatever the [__] she
was saying and then it ends and she
starts again all right I hear it I hear
it and she's like are you guys ready
I remember there was this giant guy with
this head that weighed as much as my
body and I could see him standing over
everybody and he was I just saw the side
of his face in the complete lack of
synapses firing and he's like squinting
and she was going like are you [__]
ready are you ready to get in the
[__] Mario right and he was just like
he just opened his mouth and exhaled was
like
[Laughter]
right
and then she did it and she had the
balls the [__] cojones to do it again
you guys can I say I'm [__] ready and
finally
this one dad who the only person with
self-esteem less just went like yeah
we've been waiting for two and a half
[__] hours right he didn't say [__]
and she had the balls to be like what
and he goes we've been waiting for two
and a half hours and I hated myself that
I didn't say yeah
exactly
what do you think we're doing here this
is a horrible experience not worth the
wait
we realized that an hour and 10 minutes
in but there was no way to get out we
were just surrounded and there was metal
on both sides it was like the Ron
Burgundy I'm trapped in a glass house of
emotion
so finally we get in there we go into
another [__] room
they closed the door and this [__]
guy's talk I can't at this point I don't
even remember what happened then we went
to the final last thing it's like okay
this is what you got you got to put the
thing on and then put the glasses on and
then you gotta [__] this is shooting
and all of this stuff and then we got on
and it was like [__] three and a half
minutes
and the whole that's it
and the whole [__] thing was over and
we in there I couldn't tell what I was
shooting at and all this type but I
don't play I'm not a video game guy
right you know what I mean I drank beers
right I [__] hung out with the fellas
I could throw a ball all right
I lived my childhood outside in reality
I didn't stay inside friendless jerking
off pretending I was a Navy SEAL
playing
siphon filter well actually I played
that game
we ended up getting out of there right
I'm trying to work on not cursing in
front of my kids and we sat down at to
eat a crusty burger
at The Simpsons part of the park
and I finally like my wife's going like
so do you want to go down and go on the
uh the Jurassic
Jurassic [__] Velociraptor [__]
ride and I just I couldn't hold it
anymore I go I'm [__] wiped I I can't
I still want to do this anymore like
you know if this is like the end of the
relationship I'm actually
I don't know if I have an inmate to like
save it and if you just wanna
meet some other guy here with Mouse ears
that has a little better attitude about
this types of things like I'm sure we
can work on a financial settlement but I
am [__] I am [__] out of here like
I can't I literally can't [__] do
this anymore oh it's great when you
leave when you leave they're like [__]
you like you got to go all the way out
this way and where all the fatties come
in they got this wide birth and you just
gotta walk all the way you're seeing the
Shrubbery it's so bad because you can
see like Civilization like oh my God
look at those houses that have air
conditioning and stuff you're [__]
just walking out
yeah
but the best part was we got home and
like my daughter fell asleep and
everything and she came in and her Nana
was there and she was like how was it
and she was just like it was
unbelievable and she totally flipped out
and everything I was like all right
thank God it's always worth it so in a
way that was an endorsement
laughs